new zealand is up in its measures to
come back to cove at 19 after several
confirmed cases of the immigrant variant
prime minister jacinda aden says the
nation is now under a red alette aden
has followed her government's guidelines
and has postponed her own wedding which
was shadowed for next weekend
staying with the pandemic government
around the world are tracking the spread
of what is considered to be an offshoot
of the omicron variant
scientists have labeled it b a dot 2.
it's nicknamed the stealth variant
because it's more difficult to detect
and it has become an increasingly
dominant source of coronavirus
infections in denmark and india
let's bring in professor tobias kurt
he's an epidemiologist and works at the
charity hospital in berlin hello sir so
we are already struggling to deal with
omicron and now there's a stealth
version of it how dangerous is this
sub-variant
it's difficult to say at this moment
we're waiting for data to really judge
how transmissible this virus is this new
variant is and how severely people get
infected we also need to weigh data if
vaccination helps which however is
expected
so
where has this sub-variant been detected
so far
india denmark as you said i think also
in the uk and it's expected to also
appear in other countries
really how concerned should we be though
i think we shouldn't be more concerned
than we were before the situation will
remain dynamic new variants variants
will appear
as as
many people get infected new variants
will develop and and so it's really up
to us to get vaccinated to
stop the spread of the virus on the
global level
and overall what impact is this going to
have on how we tackle the pandemic going
forward
i think it will not have a different
impact than the measures that we already
taken i think vaccination is really
important and getting data to really
judge new variants and be ready to
potentially also
have different measures in place
okay
um professor tobias kurt at charity
hospital in berlin thank you
thanks for having me
you